It took ages to pull away from the dragnet
of suburban houses, industrial parks and warehouses..
Now, at last, the open road, 120 more miles
of it. They'll be asleep when we finally pull
up, and fumble in the darkness for the key
below the old earthenware jar.
It takes only a miniscule pressure for the
machine to surge forward.
The hidden world of technicians that made it possible: the cylinders fashioned somewhere in industrial
Japan, the oil in the tank from the Arabian
deserts.
Every mile took two weeks to build. The base
layer, the limestone, the precast slabs, the
jet black asphalt, the perfect white and yellow
lines. And the band of men from from Lublin
or Madjanek who put it together so well that
you’d never have to give them or their work
a moment’s thought.
Alongside in other lanes, trucks carry massed
parts of the nation's needs: scissors, lampshades,
biscuits, things that will be part of someone's
bedroom, accompaniments to a meal.
As children we could be curious and wave.
Now we must stare ahead,
pretending not to care.
Neglected parts of one’s inner life emerge
on the road. Ideas, associations, feelings.
Driving is an unexpected tool for thinking.
Out here it becomes less frightening to look
inside us. One can always draw away, to the
clouds and the vast horizon.
Out here we're readier to forgive, to feel love
and to dare to hope again.
With the stereo, we can put on extraordinary
sound-and-image shows: symphonies, requiems,
and love songs choreographed to the beauty
of the fugitive landscape.
In the service station in the gathering darkness,
it feels easier to love humanity.
Everyone is a stranger here. We can guess
at the sorrows that brought them to this place.
- perhaps a father who sees them only once
a month.
- a disappointed participant in a meeting
hastily arranged online.
The sadness is not necessarily depressing.
Everybody is a little dislocated.
The loneliness we carry about inside us meets with the loneliness
of others - and is redeemed.
Then back out to the car, hours still to go.
The instruments will glow in the darkness,
stars will appear over head while peculiar,
valuable ideas emerge in the cocoon of the
cabin and we are surreptitiously returned
a little to ourselves.